hey guys Ryan right here tonight I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for Sin
City DOS I'm excited to watch this
trailer I [ __ ] love Sin City the
first trailer for this movie freaked me
the [ __ ] out cannot wait to watch this
trailer here it's like the full
theatrical one why are we still talking
let's get this show on the road
the most powerful man that's pretty hot
yeah oh [ __ ]
voice is gonna rock gonna team up itself
you know [ __ ] Rock
pressure
No
I am overwhelmed with anxiety right now
I feel like I just want to watch the
[ __ ] movie already yeah I can't wait
for this film III did not even think
about like what if they decided to
actually have them cross past this time
around they really crossing paths holy
[ __ ] yeah that okay
whoa Mickey Rourke looks like he's gonna
rock it again [ __ ] Joseph
gordon-levitt man dude and you got Bruce
Willis doing his Bruce Willis hardigan
things Jessica Alba being a sexy ass
[ __ ] I kind of like the new look on
Jessica Alba [ __ ] Josh Brolin dude
how awesome is this movie gonna be Sin
City this is no Sun anyway thank you
guys for informing me that that trailer
was out if you're new to the channel
subscribe cuz midnight ryan was filming
really late again and she walked in she
had hair as long as the SIOC with tits
the size of an antelope I'm really bad
at film-noir I'm so stoked for that
trailer man man [ __ ] do you that I got
like a tingle in my balls right now that
movie looks so cool I want to get some
shout outs Luke Gallagher said hey the
real rejects I recently subscribed to
you guys and gals but mostly Ryan of
course and I'm looking for a shout out
well yet found it I shared your Godzilla
movie clip reactions with my mates and
now I have to go see the film alone cuz
I spoil the movie for them but hey
you'll win some you lose some and
sometimes you get your [ __ ] Zack that's
fair
fun times man fun times anyway love your
videos i watch all of them when they
come out and then I feel lonely again
well what a dark note to end um but I
know what you mean it's kind of like
masturbating like you get so into porn
and then suddenly right when it's over
you're like oh no no that was real for
me I know but thanks man
no it's really cool that you're a
subscriber [ __ ] dude [ __ ] sometimes you
do your dicks like maybe I'll suck your
dick with it if Rama Gaulle said huge
fan of yours Ryan love your videos can I
get a shout-out please with your glasses
on haha
well if I'm a girl you got it I know you
like a guy with glasses and sometimes
the glasses do look better I'm the sexy
[ __ ] that's what I am demon
sorrows this dude posted a long-ass
comment on one of my videos the students
awesome I like comments like that maybe
I don't reply back as much as
trying to keep up with all the comments
now but when someone gets that into
depth with a comment and like really
analyzes something and reviews it
themselves I find that pretty awesome
man and I think you should stop up your
own YouTube channel TIFF demon sorrows
yeah it really dark name a lot of
youtubers got really dark names you guys
need to find God or something